Now the Hello World project here that you've got, it's
a very simple, application that uses end points. What I want
to do now is just talk you quickly through the code
so that you understand how to define endpoints, so you see
how to call them from a web page. So let's
take a look at the files in the Hello World end
points application. So here, you see here in src > main
> java. In the com > google > training > helloworld
package, you see the Java files.
There are three Java files, Constants.java, HelloClass.java
and HelloWorldEndpoints.java. So Constants.java defines some constants,
as you might expect. HelloClass.java is a
very simple class we'll look at
in a minute. And then HelloWorldEndpoints.java defines
the endpoints used in the application. So
the source dir, contains the main folder,
which contains the java and the webapp folders.
We just looked at java, but now we're
going to look at webapp. So the webapp
folder contains the static files, the index.html, other
HTML files if you have them, JavaScript files,
any static content. It also contains the WEB-I-N-F,
or WEB-INF folder. And this folder's common to
all web applications, and it's where you configure
your application. So for app engine apps, you have
to have the appengine-web.xml file, which we already looked at,
which is where you configure the things that are specific
to your app engine app in, particular, you have to
specify the app ID if you want to deploy it
to Appspot. Another file in here is web.xml. And let's
take a quick look at that. So web.xml is where
you'd configure servers if you have them. In your web.xml
you should see that you have
the SystemsServiceServlet. And
it's mapped to com.google.api.server.spi.SystemServiceServlet.
And this spi, means end points. So this servlet is crucial to your application,
if you want to use end points.
Basically you must have com.google.api.server.spi.SystemServiceServlet in your
app if you want to use endpoints. Also see we define the welcome file
here which is index.html, which is pretty much
the default. Another configuration I want to draw your
attention to, is this one here for the
security constraint, where we specified that all web pages
must use HTTPS and this is how we
specify it, by setting the transport guarantee confidential. So
whenever you see this in your web.xml, it just
means that when the app's running on app spot,
if the user goes to it without using
HTTPS, they'll be redirected to HTTPS. Okay, so back
in the webapp dir, you see there's also
hello.js. And there's index.html. And these are the two
files that this app uses in the web
UI, or in the web front-end. Hello.js contains the
JavaScript functions used by the app, and index.html
is the home page for the app, and it
shows the two buttons, and the input field. And
here you see the two buttons, and the input failed.